so can i refresh or no
we should be good here
so let's let me i'm gonna i'm gonna like
refresh the facebook groups and see
if we're showing up or gnaw
okay
um
i hate that
okay
and muffled
let's see here
let's try to fix that no yoshi's oh but
i think
that may have been
from the previous stream
oh okay
i think maybe this is so funny
i just love that we
came in hot like yo y'all we got a real
show today y'all
and we're gonna start by having real
technical difficulties real technical
difficulties
but we in here now we are
yay
ron jammin said buttered ass ftw
so what's up fellas what's up ron
you bike
i don't know what what does ftw mean
for the win
oh okay
so thank you all for your patience here
this is you know just like anything else
you do just like stand up it's a lot of
trial and error and repetitions we
appreciate all his patience
it should be better though let us know
if it looks better if it sounds better
yoshi give him some audio there i'm
sorry i'm hogging all the fun
no it's all good i'm right here
hopefully y'all can hear me oh yeah
mookie said loud and clear all right
perfecto
all right
i really didn't have my wedding ring on
what a sinner
all right we're we're back baby thomas
said we're back a hundred percent better
said lee funny
mookie said here y'all loud and clear
awesome
yeah yay yay
thank you all for jumping in here oh
this is gonna be so much fun we have we
have some topics to tackle
um and based on
some question jaws in the facebook group
as well
so
welcome to hot breath live if you're not
subscribed to our youtube channel
for all this awesome freeness you're
getting all we ask
in return as you subscribe to the
youtube channel
um
perfect yoshi what's your social media
ron jamming's trying to holla
that's social
at sorry i said at social
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh i'm tripping um at dj yoshi on
instagram and at yoshi i'll i'll say it
at dj yoshi
ig
and then
twitter
is yoshi
i've had so many jobs
oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah if you're you're full-time comedian
you know you gotta
you're brand you're mr marketer you know
branding
i know right
i can make a lot of money for a lot of
people
but myself but when it comes that's all
yep that's the hard part
nice oh zeb said he's booked at the
comedy catch that week and congrats that
be working now he'd be getting some gigs
out there now
well done dude yeah i'm on my space too
ron jammin you can also find me on black
planet
all the old school joints limewire
you know napster
holo
well as people are coming in not
everyone came back to the live stream
from the last one but there that maybe
they're finding it but in the meantime
in between time i think it's time
we
jump into it here you ready yoshi
do it
let go
all right here we go my friends
officially welcome to the right hot
breath club dang hot breath club
hot
so
we have quite a lot to get to today so
here's the rundown look how fancy we are
this is so legit yo this is so legit
so we have a few um
pressing
topics in the comedy game that i think
it's like must hear for all comics and
then we have a few
more
personal kind of questions we're going
to answer based on people in the
facebook group and conversations going
on there
and then we're going to hook you up with
some joke feedback so first things first
we've been talking oh this is our set
list yo hot breath set list
that's not a terrible
yeah that's not bad i don't hate that
ron that hot breath set list
that's not bad at all that's lit i
really like that
so um first things first
we are for comics by comics and
we've been talking about the earthquake
special and i've got to tell you dude
the earthquake special has ruined comedy
for me like
[Laughter]
i was watching ronnie chang's new
special
yeah and like
it was really it was funny and it was
interesting and it was engaging and
captivating but there was a moment near
the middle
that i i i was watching with my wife and
i audibly said out loud i was like yo
where's the laughs like
because he was setting up a point
that took a little while to get there
but seeing what earthquake did i was
just like yo
lpm's lpms lpms where's the last per
minute
yeah but yeah that's what i thought
about
yeah it was different i would say the uh
the um
aziz on sorry special
yeah
that one was so short and felt like an
earthquake special
because he did it in a tight space
and the laughs carried
so that would felt
like an earthquake like special because
it was very much like hit hit hit hit
and he did it like in a very i mean in a
30-minute kind of like environment but
yeah it's that that earthquake special
is
especially like as the big one for 2022
has kind of ruined
a lot of people's like
expectations of what a special should be
it it's another level and i think i
think it can ruin also
maybe
like stylistically like
yeah there doesn't have to there doesn't
have to be 12 laps per minute you know
as comedians we can appreciate that
metric and aspire to it but there is
also something to be said about having a
point developing it
yes and i mean
it's got to be funny i know there's also
a trend where it's cool to not get
laughs because you're ironically bombing
but
i we do need to make sure there's still
laughs there but also
if you have something to say
to feel comfortable saying it and being
in silence and establishing it for the
payoff at the end
but i do always have yes we're going to
talk about gerard carmichael's new
special
uh who his all of his specials are a
prime example of someone
doing what they want to do having a
clear stylistic choice
and committing to it and it's not
earthquake
like laughs per minute but um
it's another way to do comedy and that's
what we always want to encourage comics
is like
the only way is your way you can learn
from us and the classes and workshops
and other comics but at the end of the
day there's no right way it's your way
but at least make it funny you know be
funny yeah but gerard special is like a
unique example of how to do a comedy
special
yeah it's very different it's funny
because i was watching the carmichael
special
and i was doing my homework and i was
counting the laughs per minute and then
i just put my pencil down and i just
said that's not what this is about right
and
i finished the rest of the special and i
still enjoyed it i i enjoyed it but it
wasn't
it wasn't i wouldn't actually call it
a comedy special
i'd call it a special
starring the comedian gerard carmichael
and the reason i say that
is
it was more like
a
like a come to jesus moment kind of
thing it was more like
it felt like an intervention but we
weren't trying to intervene in anything
that jerrod was going through we were
just in a room where he's like it's you
know what it was it felt like you did
you ever have family meetings
where everyone's like hey guys gather up
where your dad's like gonna tell you big
news right and he's like we're gonna
move to like virginia right i remember
this because we had a family meeting
where my dad like he goes through he's
like this is why we're moving all this
other stuff
that's what the gerard carmichael
special felt like he's like all right
everybody gather around everyone that i
know gather around let me tell you the
story about my
like
what i'm going through and that's what
that special felt like and i enjoyed it
for that
and took off the lens of trying to make
it like
oh this is
this is just all pure comedy and he had
jokes throughout it but he also
forcefully also did things that you
aren't necessarily supposed to do in
comedy
and i appreciate that he did do that
because he had audience members asking
questions and
answer them
as part of the special
and the questions weren't comedic
questions they were like hey how do you
feel about your mom
like there were hard-hitting questions
about the situation that he's going
through so it like i think you just have
to respect that the special itself was
more like a family meeting a family get
together let's gather around gerard's
got something to say
and it was i i enjoyed it because i
thought it was super artistic
i agree and i enjoyed it as well and i i
think i'm glad that this came out
um just because we had been leaning on
laughs per minute so much so i'm glad
as we continue to do this show that we
can start to kind of
look at it from multiple angles and
don't because a lot of young comics
listen to this and i don't want people
to start thinking oh there wasn't a
laugh every five seconds so it's not a
good special like so i think this is a
great time for this special to come up
just for that reason if anything to show
what's possible you know bo burnham
directed it who
boze directed other of gerard's specials
i think he directed chris rock's newest
special
um so uh it's yes stylistically it's
super unique super
specific to gerard gerard and like ron
said it's like a one-man show
yeah which is a good way to put it yeah
yeah
and i i think what i really took away
from it
and it's something that he emphasized in
the special
i think at one point someone yelled out
and then
maybe like retreated a little bit he's
like no please like speak up you know i
think what he said like we're a family
like this is how this it's only gonna
work if we feel like we're in a family
together or something like that so he
set that expectation too
for sure yeah yeah and i so respected
the audience for like
taking themselves
and putting themselves into his shoes
and like really cleaning into like
because
there were times when like the
conversation felt uncomfortable
you're like
wow like
he's going through it and you can see
him going through it
on stage
yeah
he's processing
deep emotions
while doing a comedy special
and to watch that and to also watch the
audience be engaged in that was actually
very
kind of cool it was something i've never
i've never seen
that before
where
an artist
is like
having a moment
and then
an audience is watching the moment there
were a lot of
silences
that were quiet
and just like you could hear a pin drop
and you were just
waiting
for something to break it but it was
also okay that it wasn't broken as well
yeah yeah i think i heard a musician i
came here which one it was but they said
like
you can make an audience clap but can
you make an audience quiet as well and
he made the audience quiet and i i i'm
guilty of this of like hiding behind
laughs sometimes and like and not going
there but making the easy joke to escape
the discomfort that this topic may be
bringing up
so sure watching this as someone 12
years in the game i was like
i want to be more
thoughtful and intentional one he opens
up let's talk about secrets so
immediately i'm like well what are some
of my secrets and could i talk about
these things you know because i do
i do want to get more personal now i
feel like i'm in like kind of the next
chapter of my career and like
i i do want to get deeper and talk about
more personal things
and seeing the special really kind of
inspired me to be like okay well this is
how it's done at the top this is how
it's done at the highest level are you
willing to do this and um it really
inspired me to like really kind of
start going to those places and asking
well what are my secrets and maybe
am i comfortable talking about them you
know it's it's scary and he does it i
mean beautifully
yeah yeah yeah he definitely has given a
template
to
talk about uncomfortable conversations
that you are still processing
and you don't have a solution and or a
joke for
at the moment
yep like
and
i would love to have like figured out
like
how he prepared for this
because it felt
very organic on stage
yeah yeah it did i'm i'm wondering yeah
how much it was thought out versus just
like i'm gonna go up there and talk
about this you know and i guess the big
thing
that happens in the special like the
headline is gerard comes out in his
comedy special you know he like he
basically says i'm gay and then there's
like applause and he was on seth meyers
and talk he's like i came out in my
special and people like applaud and he's
like i love being in new york people
just applaud me for being gay now he's
like
but it's like you could you could see
him like like mindfully like talking
through this like he's trying to figure
it out with the audience which was very
interesting to see adam
on a special
yeah
so i think that's the big takeaway for
comics is like
yeah how can you create a connection
with the audience you know like create
an authentic connection that's memorable
that you actually feel
you know it's another thing i've been
watching american idol
you know with my with my wife you know
we like the american idol and the best
the best singers
your wife doesn't have to be the excuse
for you watching american eye don't you
guys go with it yo i'm with it
i'm with it yo
i love it i really do and my favorite
singers are the ones that you can feel
what they're singing
and like you feel the emotion and i was
like can people do that with my comedy
you know we tell comics to write from
emotional places like but am i doing
that and how can i do it better because
i want i want to evoke that emotion and
that connection with the audience like
gerard does it's
it it's it's a new level and i think
everyone should definitely check it out
and it's also why
i think he's got so many fans um
like there are people that just f with
gerard carmichael that are like yo
that dude's got something
and he's just got a fandom that is very
like
unique that people just mess with them
and mind you this is a guy who's already
had a network television show
he's already had several specials he's
kind of doing comedy at his own pace
like he's just doing exactly what he
wants to do in comedy um and he's doing
it like his way so just to put something
out like this i really like it because i
feel like there isn't a template for
something
of this nature
really yeah
so yeah i i i definitely i enjoyed it i
agree
yes
i was like oh i needed that it was like
oh just
you just don't get a lot of there's not
a lot of gerard carmichael's in the game
oh my god i mean well yeah there's
clearly only like one gerard like even
the comment the special he did at the
comedy store
he's like using a notebook here's a
notebook during a comedy special
and i personally what that was produced
by spike lee yeah spicy who's that
special
one of the greatest directors of all
time produces special and this dude has
a notebook it was just
yeah like
just the the breakage and just like oh
let me just do it my way
so
yeah it's just it's very like
high quality but also just like very
admirable
yeah yeah so check it out comics and
just see what's possible in this format
um
but you know funny you know please do be
funny i i don't want people to be like
all right never mind i don't want to be
a comedian i want to do ted talks at
open mics you know still be funny
but
you see you see how gerard
when you watch the special you'll see
how he walks the line from both but
everything's very intentional he's not
like i want to say something
risque just for the sake of people like
tweeting about it like what he's doing
is very intentional and it's done at a
very high level
but it's also aspirational for like the
connection he creates with the audience
so
watch it through that lens
that's solid
awesome all right well let's move on
here as we got peeps ryan is in the
building
good to see you ryan ryan
ryan he came to that he came to the
norcross show and he's been around now
it's good to see you ryan
um
yep thomas in here and hannah it's great
to see all y'all thanks for hanging out
in here and bobby in here so
one
topic
we must discuss we've talked about ali
wong this week or the past few weeks but
ali wong
after eight years of marriage is getting
a divorce
yeah man
um
i i am not
i'm surprised but i'm not that surprised
yeah i mean everything i've read that it
was amicable and they're still going to
be co-parenting and it
um and i also
i think in her book she mentions that
they did sign a prenup and whatnot
um but so no more d i haven't heard any
details about the why or how
for sure
but
i mean we can speculate we're comedians
yeah
but that's we're both like you and i are
both married
and
it can be
difficult you know i mean hey just just
do taxes with your spouse and let her
see what comedy
that's all you really need to do uh to
see how your spouse really feels about
all these comedy shows you're doing
oh
but i think i think it is interesting
it's interesting topic yeah for people
who
won or married or wanting to date or
wanting to pursue comedy but also have a
life i think i've heard i think maybe
dan soder said on the podcast or
one of like one of the new york comics
was like my advice to young comics is
don't date anyone for like the first
five years of comedy or whatever maybe
it was an apartheid no because he was
they
someone said don't date because comedy
is your life for a long time so it's a
tough balance you know
and you have kids too
yeah i mean i think
without a doubt the element of ally wong
being super successful
being a female comedian and just being
like and i only want to say female and
just being a comedian at the top of
the game is going to have challenges
like
for sure
in a marriage right yeah i think it's so
fascinating that we've watched her
transition from
each of the specials around like her at
the start of her success her husband
being like the main
uh bread winner in the family and how
that transitioned to like the her being
the main breadwinner in the family it's
you know it's complicated
you know i've i've been a retired trophy
husband like i was the trophy husband
and then i became like the other side of
it as well so it's
and i'm not anywhere close to ali wong's
like
nowhere close to like what she's pulling
in right but
it's tough because like that shift of
breadwinner-ism
kind of changes you you i mean like it
kind of changes the dynamic
where i would say
where some people aren't like that
comfortable being like
the stay-at-home
dad
you know i mean like
yeah a thing that most people
may
like enjoy you know i'm saying or they
weren't necessarily expecting it either
but it's also
like the lifestyle of a comedian is not
for everyone like
when you're you're on the road
like
all the times the travel
i mean she was doing movies like and
like that's
you're not
with that person like
that person isn't there you know what
i'm saying like
uh
yeah it's not easy for sure so like the
money can only get you so far it's like
oh you being gone all the time we're
multi-millionaires
but it's also like hey we have two kids
and a family
and like and i'm not speculating what
went wrong with her marriage at all i
just know from personal experience and
friends in this game
that like the light that road life of
always being gone
can re at first it's like yeah i know
that's part of the job but when it
becomes reality
there's lonely you know i was in l.a was
supposed to be for a week ended up being
two weeks because i got sick like that's
at a very low level but that's still
randomly in the middle of the month i'm
like i'm gone for two weeks you know
across the country so it's it's it's
difficult
yeah yeah yeah
i mean laying it out to your spouse like
letting them know ahead of time
like before my wife and i before she
even moved down here i was like
i love the idea but just know i'm like
gone like every night like because
here's the thing that yes that's helpful
that's very very helpful
but it reaches a different category
because i don't think allie wong knew
the level of success that she was going
to get to oh
you know
like
and now not that she's not deserving of
it like she deserves all of it and she's
very skilled it's just like
that
when those i mean i don't know i i feel
like
when you get to like seven eight
figures
the game changes son
yeah yeah i'm excited to find out
[Laughter]
it just it just changes and so like but
also the expectations and so like
you gotta be so established like in the
marriage and
i think that's the other thing is like
kids also complicated and then the
rearing of the kids
and it's like
well
where to your point where is daddy going
also where's mommy going if mommy's the
comedian
doing all the comedy like work like ali
wong like you just never know i mean and
again we're all speculating here
but
we kind of
there's without a doubt obviously
something went wrong in the marriage and
i have a hard time believing that comedy
not a factor yeah
yeah yeah yeah
so i think for people oh and we have uh
za from malaysia in here yo this is sick
yo thank you everyone for watching and
hanging out and tuning in here um
so yeah i think i think so some people
may be watching this and are like
all right i'm married how can i how can
i balance comedy of marriage or i'm
dating or i'm thinking about dating it's
like i think for me
i think it's
what just being transparent with your
significant other like being transparent
this is just the reality this is my i
love doing this this is my job or i
aspire to make this my job these are the
sacrifices and also i think
like ahead of time getting that out in
front and then checking in and like
being like
how is this going for you i was just
gone for a week like how like really
keeping an open line of communication
not taking it personally but also having
to understand
what we do as comedians
is not normal
it's not like you know me i remember
early on driving 12 hours for like 50
bucks you know
for like 20 minutes and bombing not
bombing but for 12 hour drive it was a
bomb i will say
that's not normal and it's hard for
people to understand
with a 401k and like
a job like people
it's hard for them to understand and
grasp it so it's it's important to have
an open line of communication
at all times about
second
game changer it's the being honest about
okay how is it how's it going now
and like what are you doing
to make this work i mean i know i went
to a period where
i was doing it like
every other night and then i had to
check in
and the reality was like yo
i need you at the house more nights and
i was like
how could i do more on the nights that
i'm
doing comedy and so i try to like pack
it in it's like and it became three open
mics a night rather than three nights a
week it was like how can i pack in
these this this time
um
and so yeah i think it's just important
to have that open line of communication
and know that yeah it's gonna change
because you know your spouse changed
your life changes like i mean there was
a time when i was like yo babe
i'm going full time in this and i was
like a year in oh and that was a bad
time to go full time into this right but
she was so supportive right
and then like the reality sort of
checked in like i'm not even good at
this yet i'm just starting this and so
like just making sure that
that open line of communication is there
is very helpful
i agree yeah and um abby i hope i'm
saying that right ob here abby let me
know um this is their first time tuning
in so thank you
um
but uh they say i think it boils down to
your own time management my girlfriend
has been super supportive of my comedy
but when it's our time i better be
paying full attention and i'm mindful of
that as well that it is like
when i'm with family i'm a hundred
percent there i'm not like creating
content
like i am with there
so your sign says be intentional be
present
yeah
yeah man like that's so key is that when
you're doing family time
be there when you're doing comedy be
there
like yeah and all like just yeah don't
don't be like hey
i got this joke
while you're having dinner like
some other kind of stuff not that that
doesn't come up but like be there like
if it's a joke about something you're
talking about then that's okay but like
don't be like
all right let me run these bits by you
real quick because i got this set coming
up in a couple of days it's like yo she
doesn't want to hear all that and just
and just like
they support you
support them just as much and whatever
it is they're doing even if they're
talking about something happening at
work listen be there
contribute like as comedians we can be
very selfish and be like it's us all the
time
or whatever but like be sure as much as
they support you to reciprocate that so
even when you're not there they still
feel supported in a part of what you're
doing making them a part of it
is another aspect of it so it's
it's it's really yeah it's unfortunate i
hate i mean you know i've i've gone
through
uh two divorce i haven't been divorced
but like my parents have been divorced
twice
so like i i divorce is no joke and it's
not fun it's not something people
just do on a whim so um i hope the best
for ally
but um yeah it's not a great situation
but hopefully maybe this will bring up
the topic of like
pursuing comedy having like a healthy
work-life balance and just understanding
like the relationship the life side of
being a comedian that people probably
don't think about but it's it's it's
important and it's tricky
facts
nice keller reeves in here what's goodie
fam
oh this is great oh and abby okay it's
abby awesome
oh and they did um
they were posting photos
because her husband's asian they were
posting photos of her with the wrong
asian guy
apparently there's a hashtag like
hashtag wrong asian
that like people just post the wrong
asian so i think it was
pack
randall pack or something yeah
she did a movie with them she was they
were posting photos of them
they were what
she was she she was
she played her
rando pack played her husband
in a movie
and so they put that up as getting
divorced but it's also the wrong asian
oh boy
all right but yeah thank you all for
contributing it as well um
we appreciate y'all's feedback as well
oh and john said her husband gets half
the money right they now they had a
prenup yeah yeah i think prenup was more
on the fact that the husband
wasn't gonna like
i think it was more to protect him
not necessarily to protect her i think
it was a prenup like yo
we're gonna likely just do our own
things because i've got this money saved
up or whatever because he was doing like
super well when they got together but i
i don't know what the prenup says i'm
just thinking like
yo if you had a prenup usually a prenup
means
whatever we make separately in our own
profession
we get to keep
yeah so just keep that in mind my
friends in any relationship keep them a
part of your own comedy career uh as
much as they support you support them in
just communication isn't it crucial
get that prenup
oh and ryan hit us with a super chat
let's go
that's the one thing i'm going to tell
my wife today then i got a super chat
you can't tell me nothing
we made 99 cents today so
we out yeah we made it thank you so much
ryan we do appreciate that
that's awesome yeah
um
so
let's um
the next few are some questions we had
in our facebook group
uh that we'll let's do some high-level
answering of these and let's get to the
joke feedback because i'm sure some
people are like what the huh what am i
doing
so um
but hey these are all relevant topics
all right it's not just writing a joke
and getting feedback i mean there's a
lot to this game and we want to help you
all with all of it so
the uh the first question talks about
comedy festivals and this is from joyce
lyles basically her asking like
submitting the festivals how do you know
when you're ready
which one should you submit to
and um honestly personal experience
i haven't really done that many
festivals i haven't really participated
in that many festivals
um
but
i can share my two cents but what what's
your take on that yoshi
i've submitted to a lot of festivals and
i'm about like
two and forty
so just know that like it's not
it's not like a guaranteed thing that
you're gonna get in
i i did them just to like
see what happens and in some festivals i
appreciate the festivals that provided
feedback those are always great because
they have a world series of comedy does
that yeah yeah they provide feedback to
let you know you know this is why
either you got in or why you did get in
that's always helpful i say if you got
the money
submit but i there is an art to what you
do submit
and i learned this from world series and
some of the folks there and i remember
even like
there was a
like a class that we took there
where all the uh
i think
five of the clubs that were there just
did like a session and one of the things
that they said is like if you're doing a
five minutes and you're submitting even
for like a show
this is super important just straight up
facing straight because the
the festivals want to see your
expressions so that's helpful that's one
tip
tip number two
if you're editing always start with you
do not start with a host start with you
as the first thing that a festival sees
um
and then the third thing
is also like know that even bookers and
comedy festival goers that are that are
sort of
doing the contest
they may not watch your entire like five
minutes or your entire seven minute
special
so you have to almost rearrange your set
to like where your stuff that hits
really hard goes up top
and you still have to have like a good
five minute set but hit them with your
best stuff
up top those are the tips i can give for
festivals but if you've got the means i
say go for it um
you're gonna get a lot of rejections
because everyone's sort of applying but
i would find the ones that like either
like are close to you that you can
travel
uh to just quickly um and try it out i
always say also if you've got like a
local festival like in your town like if
you're in atlanta apply to atlanta
festival you're already in town just go
ahead and do that um but yeah but you do
have to have a strong
five minute
seven ten minute set
um depending on what the festival uh is
is asking for but most festivals ask for
a strong five minutes so you would say
don't submit because that's joyce asks
like when do you know when you're ready
is it like when you have like a solid
five-minute set
when you have a solid five-minute set
not to do like lpms or anything but like
it can't be below like four laps per
minute lpm's matter on like a five
minute set and like a submission set
yeah we're talking about gerard who's
doing like an hour but like a comedy
special but like yeah laughs per minute
definitely you want to pack them in
there especially when it's like a
submission set for sure yeah first so
for a submission set within five minutes
like
anything below four just isn't likely
going to cut it like you need like
like to get in there and three is
what you know that's what you teach
right you teach like first time comics
just try to go for three like if you're
getting four but like if you're in the
five to six range that's when you're
like hitting your stride for sure
yeah so get a tight five
and then start submitting to the to the
festivals and like and then they're
great for networking if anything you
know you're gonna meet a lot of other
motivated comedians and they're the best
thing about festivals are the networking
i would say i mean i think that's the
biggest value add of it so it can be
worth it if you have the means and um
the time and the ability to travel and
such and that networking is so big
because i will say even until this day
and i've been in the game for seven
years
the majority of the bookings that i've
gotten have come from other comedians
yeah for sure is it clubs it hasn't been
from
bookers it's been from other comedians
now bookers and clubs have booked me and
festivals have booked me
but where i get my work is from other
comics
yeah and i don't think um
she asked about the best festivals to
submit to i'm kind of out of the game i
mean i know
world series is good i've heard
limestone
big large
sky
um
thousand i think it's a thousand miles
the one in
um
minneapolis
thousand lakes is also pretty solid even
uh what's the one that's in new york
the devil
something laughing devil
yeah something like that there's one
goldfest here in atlanta is good
i think red play
i would say before you submit ask like
even just post on our facebook group and
ask before you submit um because
but like the limestones and like
even like the limestone
um and big sky
those festivals like
i would say do not submit to that as
your first festivals mm-hmm i know i'm
breaking protocol here
but like
that's like
big time
you gotta have like not that you have to
have representation but
you gotta be like in the game game
before
you get that like
they're
likely are not booking first year second
year comics
yeah and we say that hey you may submit
for the first time in your new comic and
you may get in like
there's
what i just there's no one way to do
this it's just based on what we've seen
right yeah yeah for sure you know the
mold can be broken like rosebud like got
into jfl four years in like we've seen
people get into jfo two years in like
yeah it's half people in this city
gotten into jfl two years into comedy so
there's you know the rules are meant to
be broken for sure
yeah and if you hear us like i'm going
to prove them wrong please go i mean
we're literally just trying to give you
our professional opinion but there's no
one way in this comedy game for sure
yeah for sure yeah if you prove us wrong
and you're like yo i made it into the
festival like i i'ma buy you a cake
you're saying like
if hey
for sure
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh and denise said world comedy expo in
chicago the first one was this past
march yeah i saw people posting from
there she said it was excellent well run
nice yes there's good festivals out
there
i'm sure there there i mean there's bad
ones as well so like maybe if you're not
sure
like post on our facebook group and ask
and i'm sure
you'll get a lot of good insights into
anything you ask in there for sure
um but yeah
nice
all right the next one up
this was uh we'll try to run through it
a little faster we're like yeah we'll
just do this real quick and then we kind
of went down
nick nick baskerville had asked what
types of jobs can you get
can you do
like pursuing stand-up you know like
warm-up comic professional hosts writers
for shows
um
yeah like so other jobs you can do
beyond
just stand-up comedy i think yeah
hosting is a big one i think
you are learning the skill of public
speaking it's people's biggest fears
so
if you could public speak
you can do a lot of different things
i've hosted like award shows i've hosted
um like uh like a company parties and
things like that i mean i've been asked
to do a wedding before but it was
it was a college friend and they wanted
the buddy deal and it was really far
away and i was like nah gee
um but
yeah you can uh
[Laughter]
you can do a lot more yeah writing is a
good one uh writing for a tv show riding
funny copy for like um advertising is
another thing i've seen people do
yeah yeah there's tons of comedy jobs
out there for sure um i'd also say just
know that like as a comedian at the core
you're a writer and there's tons of
different types of writing gigs that you
can get i also say like just the
practice of like podcasting hosting
different types of stuff that's
entertaining is so important i remember
the chilewa interview
um
she mentioned on on hot breath she
mentioned
she was just like yeah like producers
and people they'd be like oh so you do
comedy
what else
oh you're right what else like they want
to see like the list of like all the
different stuff that you do because it's
like oh well we don't have a stand-up
show so what else can you do if we're
trying to put you on television there's
not a stand-up show on television so
it's like okay what are your skills you
know noah garden schwartz is a writer on
the marvelous miss maisel yep but he's a
stand-up right and it is a stand-up like
themed show so they have a lot of
stand-ups as writers for the show itself
but they also have people that are not
stand ups as writers um and so it's just
about just leveraging that comedy
writing skill yeah also other
performance like when we talk about
public speaking you know i mean acting
is clearly there like you can do improv
i've done
i've done like team building
facilitation for companies like it's
like team building games and activities
and they wanted someone like fun
interactive to run it like so there's a
lot of different things you can use
because you're developing the skill of
engaging an audience which is
very difficult and very rare so if you
can do it you can find other avenues in
this beyond just standing there with a
microphone
yo it's
you know i always say
spotify didn't pay
joe rogan
he's great at comedy
those are just facts you mean like
because
but he used that comedy skill
in his podcast he used the comedy skill
on when he's hosting shows
uh
so yeah just know that there's other
avenues to getting paid other than
standout
yeah oh and tavis said if he makes it
into jfl he'll book a hot breath show
and invite us on there
we would destroy that show oh my gosh
let's go
that was dope
i i i was i was able to go up there
um chris isn't here to flex but i did go
up there with miss pat
a few years ago and it was it's it's it
legi it lit i mean it's legit like
oh for sure i can imagine yeah you know
i mean when you're in a green room and
there's judd apatow talking to john
mullaney you're just like what the what
i mean
but i think i mean i think what that
teaches you though is like we're all
people like i think a festival if you
meet someone like
famous and they're like a person you're
like oh they're like there's someone
like they're just like me or whatever
like i i saw a comic out in la at the
comedy store and i was like oh i love
this show you're doing
uh like they posted a social media show
and they're like yeah yeah i think like
they were like kind of jittery and
nervous like they were like a nervous
anxious comedian but we see them as like
these juggernauts but they're all people
um
but yeah i said i'll just say tabs we
aren't there all right we're
no yeah please yes um all right the next
one
and this one is about characters and uh
susan hill had asked basically like how
to form a character
in your act
um
so i think it takes
i think the key is it just takes
practice
with characters especially if she's
talking about new characters or like
characters like
her own character probably like maybe
like
doing act outs i don't know that's all
she really said is like doing yeah
okay if it's that then it just takes
practice
right like
it takes practice of going into that
character um on stage
and you know when i do act outs you know
i do act out of my dad and i do act out
to my mom i do act outs of like
i've got to act out of like what i think
white people sound like i do act outs of
what i think somebody that looks like
joel sound like yeah what do white
people sound like
you know like white people
like what you don't do the the nerdy
white people
i do mine is upper class like very
hoity-toity like
oh
what is it is that how we sound
and there's also the
other levels of it right like the you
know
not that there's different levels of
white but you know there is there's 50
shades of light for sure
but yeah so i think it just takes
practice i think that's the key with
characters it's just practice it but
also remember that you just don't go
into the character the character has to
be a part of the joke
don't just say here's my impression of
this that doesn't really work like just
on a stand-up stage
versus you know my dad sounds like
uh
donald trump every once in a while and
then you go into the trump voice but
saying what your dad would say like
that's character development
yeah i think it can be helpful because
it's scary like i mean at least for me
everyone has different skills in like
their comedy arsenal but like
characters and act outs or something i'm
still and i want to be more intentional
about in this kind of this
next chapter of my career of like
getting a little more animated doing
more characters and voices or stuff
because for the longest it's just like
i'm so focused on the words and the
delivery is kind of it comes second to
that
so what's helped me to ease into that is
like doing personal characters not like
trying to do an impression which i'm now
working on a joel osteen impression
which is
um
which is all right you know
it's all right
it's an all right impression won't he
will he has risen unlike my social media
following after posting it
but um
mostly it's been like making fun of like
my family or doing my own like country
voice and things and so i think starting
from a personal place will help you to
develop characters
yeah that's solid that's good nice all
right and the final one before we get
into your joke feedback oh and john
stalling said chelsea lynn as trailer
park tammy is a great character example
yeah
for sure oh and jeremiah watkins
um
his podcast on hot breath he breaks down
how he does so many characters this guy
is like jim carrey he has a whole
like grab bag of characters he does
arsenal
yeah and he's a i could i i interviewed
him again while i was out in la
uh i didn't give him covet but um
and he he was like he he like recognized
what we're doing out here you know
because i i was like i'm always like
nervous to meet these people i'm like
i'm using up their time or whatever but
like he really like he said a lot of
good things about what we're doing here
so he he recognizes what's happening
here which is really cool um
that's awesome
but
the uh the final
question we had was from william
lombombard who basically how do you go
from set up punchline to stories
[Music]
so i think
uh
with like i think it was uh
what's
who's the
country guy we just watched the special
we just talked about it a couple weeks
ago
country guy
i say country guy just
um
i'm forgetting his name oh my god
we just did a
breakdown of a special
not earthquake
no uh
all i know is steve just gave us a 20
super chat oh my
gosh
let's
go honey
dinner's on me
and tonight go
right
um jeff foxworthy how did i forget that
yes thanks jordan jordan jeff foxworthy
thank you steve as well
so jeff foxworthy uh
and you're in the first time that you
interviewed talked about how he does
stories of just like writing out the
stories
like just as they are and then going
back in and adding the funny parts it's
kind of like how ron white does them too
right just write the story as it is and
then add funny parts all the way in
between but you got to be real with the
story first and then you add the funny
components um that's how you take
storytelling
onto the stage more is
it's not set up premise punch kind of
thing any longer it's more here's a
story now you add the funny inside of
the entire story because you can't wait
for the end of it to do the punchline
it's got to be funny all the way through
yeah that's that's definitely
uh what i heard chris titus say as well
who i don't know if if people have not
seen chris titus i mean
he's he sells out theaters he's done a
lot of things i think he's still
underrated murder
the last two comedy specials that he did
on youtube were spectacular
he does like he's a storyteller and it's
like every line is a laugh and what what
he said
um is like he writes the story out as it
happened not trying to be funny
and then like he said every detail
is like the setup for a punchline and
that's how he packs in
so many different jokes now i will also
say
that there another way if you're going
from like one-liners of storytelling
what i found a personal experience
because i personally haven't
like written out a story and then like
gone back and tried to punch it up how
my the the biggest like stories i have
like crying at my wedding is probably my
first real attempt at like a story
but
the actual story
is a bunch of individual bits
that add up to a story so it's like i
have
the story is like me getting married
planning the wedding and then the
wedding and crying at my wedding which
yoshi was there yoshi was the dj at my
wedding i am so glad there wasn't video
in hindsight i maybe wish there was
but it's like me crying a suspicious
amount is is like part of the joke
but it's a bunch of small individual
jokes that i then just organize in a way
that's more of like a story but yeah a
way to build a one-liner up even more is
just like if you have a one-liner then
it's like okay
adding tags to it
can make it more of a story than just
like a one-liner as well
sure yeah and i've done a couple of
stories i've got a couple of stories but
to your point it's like
i i think of it as here's an interesting
story i tell a story about like
an hoa that i was a part of that was
just like wild and crazy
and
like when i first tell it white claws
everywhere
but like i had i was a part of the hoa
that was just like crazy
but as i tell the story
and i when i wrote it down the first
time i did exactly what titus did just
write it out the way that it was and
then i started looking at it like
specifically like each line
where is the joke where is the funny in
each one of these things and so now that
i tell it it's probably there's probably
a joke every
one to two sentences in some form or
fashion as i'm telling a story and i
think that's the key because then when i
get to the crescendo of like the big
punch line
they didn't have to wait to laugh they
were laughing all the way through so
then when they're punched it's like oh
yay they're like the audience feels
rewarded by it so i think yeah i think
that just that premise of just tell the
story as it is and then add the funny
after you tell the story yeah simple
sweet
but it works
and then yeah and then on the other side
of it if you're writing one-liners and
you're trying to turn a one-liner into a
story
it's just expand it out like if the
one-liner is about let's just say
one-liner about crying at your wedding
okay bringing in different points of
view
can start to build into a story of like
you're talking about crying at your
wedding okay how did your wife react to
it how did your father-in-law react to
it how did the efficient react to it
like
looking at the one-liner from like 360
degrees can help you actually start to
build it out from a single line into an
entire story so
yeah there's talking about ways to do it
i think talking about what the dj
thought about you crying
while you were crying thought about what
the dj actually saw
and catching the dj's eye as you're
crying
[Laughter]
i remember i remember at one point i was
wiping my tears with my vowels i was
just like
it's wild that's
yeah it was well abby asked how do you
develop that final massive punch line uh
i think big thing for that massive final
punch line
is just working out
that you have jokes all the way through
the punchline massive punchline is just
like a normal setup premise punch kind
of thing but
because your whole story is the premise
the punchline is going to hit because
you've already set up everything else so
it's just like having a whole bunch of
setup punchlines set up punchline setup
punches on a set of punch lines
throughout your entire story but it's
all thematic
beautiful awesome
so let's get into some joke feedback
here that's so funny too
um
where'd it go when um when steve gave us
a 20 super chat john goes is the premise
that you're rich
[Laughter]
we'll take it yo what yeah we appreciate
all the support that really
it
it actually helps it goes to a good
cause
but uh yeah we appreciate y'all so yeah
we're gonna do um
a little joke feedback here so do feel
free to post your jokes just put joke in
front of it so we know to read it
um as a joke
and um maybe we'll do steve's first
because he did super chat so i think i
think that's got to be
i think maybe a new rule here is that if
you super chat you get to the top of the
list
i don't think we have the new rule i
think i guess just
like if you gonna bless us we're gonna
bless you amen
amen
for sure
so
steve he has a two-parter here
um he says
i'm
it's a joke slash premise okay
so he says i'm trying to better myself
i'm working on my confidence my goal is
to have
white woman in a crosswalk confidence
and then the act out is putting their
arm out straight
staring me down while i'm driving
holding their groceries like a football
they look like the heisman trophy i want
that care and confidence
all right
i like the premise
uh
i really do like this premise
of just you working on your confidence
so you can have
white woman crosswalk confidence
that i like i think the putting the arm
out with the
heisman
um
[Music]
i'm just not sure if it works because it
feels like you're going into another
premise
for me
but
yeah i will say it's like
i feel like
the premise he's kind of doing two ones
right now it's like i want the white
woman in a crosswalk confidence or i
want karen confidence
yeah they're kind of two different two
different ways you can take the joke
care and confidence hits me harder like
it's the double consonants it just works
better so i think to your point my goal
is to have karen
karen crosswalk confidence oh okay
that's
uh
yeah and that just sounds funny karen
crosswalk confidence yeah and then you
put your straight out stare me down
while i'm driving while holding
groceries like a football
now like the heisman trophy i'm i'm not
getting but i think you can you should
add more karen
like examples like or calling the cops
on black people while they're doing
barbecues or like other caring
karen like activities
to add to the premise of the confidence
kind of thing yeah yeah yeah yeah i
agree so it's and he said this was like
a joke's last premise so it is more of
like a premise so it is like
what are all the different
what are all the different attributes of
a karen in a crosswalk and then how can
you make them like
apply to your own life you know like
jacob said make the white woman have
care and confidence holding up holding
up traffic
is what jacob said
yeah that's funny
hold up traffic while making a call
about
that she doesn't have like she didn't
get her latte or something like that
like that's like it's almost like this
layered confidence of
this is
what i can do with all my karen ness
yeah like doing a um
joke
uh about like yeah calling
it's almost like she's jaywalking would
be a funny aspect of the joke as well
all while jaywalking could be like a tag
i want that care and crosswalk
confidence
where i'm like calling the police while
jaywalking or something like that
yeah that's clear yeah yeah that's super
clean
yeah does that i hope that helps there
um
for you there
for sure
oh i really do like that premise yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh jacob liked that
he said
[Laughter]
oh carol said cars that stopped two
centimeters over the line yeah so um
yeah so different examples of like what
a karen is doing and then how may
calling the police on the police denise
said so a lot of good ones
yeah that's funny
that's funny
all while jaywalking i really like the
jaywalking aspect of it too
yeah nice
oh
thank you
um
oh
bobby said winning the beat down on
black friday with the heisman pose
that's
with the heisman
give me that tv
oh yo we just got another super chat
from felix
yo
honey
we're getting appetizers tonight baby
we're getting appetizers tonight
the dog's getting organ organic dog food
you're getting that gluten-free baby yo
some of these dog treats are like
they have less ingredients they're
healthier than the human food now dog
food is like my dog has like
three ingredient
like you know peanut butter treats
but like it has like dates and bananas
and peanut butter i was like it ain't
that bad it doesn't taste that bad
actually
i tried them yeah
i really have
they're they're human grade dog food
he's like this is better than my stuff
i mean we'll read the ingredient label
on food i mean you need rosetta stone
so
shout out to felix yo the super chat we
out yeah
um
my heart just like smiles at that little
super chat
um
so let's see what felix said oh sorry
this is your i don't want to white i
don't want a white splain i know we
alternate sorry go ahead buddy
all right let me find you real quick
it's on the screen too
so i have something
it's kind of annoying
i'm trying to think where the joke
starts
just
i think boston
and hit your annoying co-worker day fall
on the same day i told my co-worker this
she said it's not accurate to call it a
pie because it's actually made of cake
so i slapped her
oh okay
we can just give him a refund really
quick um
all super chats are final what if that
was part of the that's like in the fine
print
[Laughter]
if we roast your joke it's the the super
chat stays
it's out of love it's definitely out of
luck so of course of course thanks for
posting feelings
a day and hit your annoying co-worker
day following the same day so i like
that premise um
it's not accurate to call it a pie
because it's
cake
so i slapped her
so i think i just feel like maybe you
just
there's just
uh
word economy here because it feels like
you're saying so many things
when the
basis of the joke is
so first of all the boston cream pie day
i'm not even sure why you need the
boston
because it doesn't do anything for the
joke
first of all if we're talking about word
economy
let's just take out that he hit a woman
that can't be your punchline
that it just cannot
so the funny thing is that was gonna be
the last thing is i just change just
change it to a dude like then i think
it's completely okay and i think i think
felix getting slapped
is funnier yeah i think it's like
we've talked about this before but like
you being the butt of the joke is always
gonna be funnier than you doing
something to like an innocent bystander
for sure yeah
so cream pie day and hit your annoying
co-worker day following the same day
i told my co-worker this
and i said
why are they calling it a pie it's a
cake so she slapped me
yes
yeah you getting hit i think i think is
the the best part of it
yeah
yeah i think that i think that works and
then maybe just like a happy
cream pie day at the end
kind of thing just like another tag on
top of it
just to hit on the
on the
fact that they're the same day
i don't know why but i feel like because
it feels so long at the beginning
oh and um denise said he gets hit with a
pie maybe he gets hit with the pie in
the face is even funnier oh that's very
funny
so she hit me with a pie in the face
yeah
that is very funny so now it's an even
more playful
like and not assault
yeah somebody said it's and it happened
on pi day so it cost me 3.14 oh my gosh
hilarious
that's solid
i like yeah i like adjusting yo felix
said it's the shortest joke i could find
in my notes yeah i think you being the
butt of the joke is always yeah i think
that's
yeah
for sure
you're the only person that can like
defend them
that's what we've learned in the last
couple weeks right joel violence is not
the answer exactly yes
exactly
amen
steve said felix got his joke from ti
[Music]
steve is on a roll that's hilarious oh
my gosh
i love it
i didn't see that coming
oh and michelle said we are we us two
are so insightful and funny oh thank you
michelle
thank you
you know
she's super chats to really get the
juices flowing
[Laughter]
but you don't have to do a super chat to
post a joke i saw sunny here said after
you save up to post a
joke oh well they also said i gotta
write something first so yeah that's a
good start as well actually writing
something
yes
oh yeah
yeah step one
feedback
write the joke yes step one right
something
oh this is great
um let's get to another joke i think
sunny earlier roasted my hair oh thanks
for everything you do joel i'm digging
the wig
this this doesn't this isn't even that
long i mean i've had much longer does it
look like a wig
the way that it's laying on top it looks
like there's a shadow right underneath
i swear it's real look i have a hairline
and everything i swear
don't let me show off my alopecia but i
do
[Laughter]
what's funny about the jada thing is i
actually do have alopecia right now
you do i do yeah
the hair thing or is it something else
is it hair
okay
i have i have like a i have like a bald
like a bald spot on my arm and then on
my legs and then i have one like
it's kind of there it's kind of going
away i've been getting like the shots
where is it it's somewhere this is why i
got online maybe it's kind of it was
there somewhere
maybe right
yeah i don't know now i'm like trying to
prove it i'm like no guys i swear i'm a
victim
[Laughter]
but yeah it's um
apparently it's stress related you know
no big deal guys just keep the super
chats coming so i can afford therapy
[Laughter]
yeah it's all good
that's funny there we go we're being
vulnerable see gerard carmichael
that that's my secret let's have
alopecia
dennis the menace
abby said look like dennis the menace oh
my gosh
i did that the um
when i did chocolate sundaes the host
roasted white people in the audience
saying dennis the menace's parents were
there
and i was up next so then i had to go up
and like thank my parents for being
there
hilarious too and i'm not even kidding i
was like i'm not doing white jokes i was
like i'm doing this set i'm not doing
any white jokes and then i was like i
mean this is an alley oop i've gotta
dunk it
so i had to do it
but i really went in like i don't want
to do white jokes because i'm really i'm
trying to
i don't know why i do that i'm like
something's working i better stop doing
it i don't
all right
anyway
let's get to the next joke here are
there other
yeah
joke are they scrolled up because i know
people posted them earlier but we went
through our so this is kind of i think
this is kind of gonna be our new format
you know we're gonna have a few topical
things and then do joke feedback you
know but um
yeah really enjoy the discussions as
well so
if you only want joke feedback just show
up later i guess
is it hannah i think it's hannah
hannah catholic
is that early early
early earlier
there she is awesome are you still with
us hannah
i hope so
hannah
we got to say something
this is you okay uh the other day i saw
a guy sitting in the transfer station
waiting for my next bus and he was sound
asleep
and he was snoring and it made me laugh
a lot
made my work day go amazingly well
okay
well i like that it's personal
but there is
i mean just observationally there's
there's no like joke structure here
right now it's kind of like a statement
yeah it's an observation it's like a
yeah it's a blanket observation like
joke structure being like set up
punchline you know so it's
you're setting up the audience to think
in one direction and then you have a
surprising
misdirect that's the punchline
yeah
so as i'm thinking about this i i like
the thought of like he was sound asleep
and he was snoring and i thought to
myself how did my husband get on this
train
you hear me like oh yes
say that wording again
uh he was sound asleep and it was
snoring
and it made me laugh because i realized
how did my husband get on the train
before i did
yeah yeah yeah so now the misdirect
is that we're assuming it's a strange or
a homeless person but it's really
your husband
yeah
but if she doesn't have a husband
um
it could be a dad it could be a son it
could be something else
i mean it could
like
i'm almost thinking like even if you say
i saw a person sitting in the transfer
station
waiting for
the next bus
and they were asleep and snoring
so i put a blanket over them even that
is funny because that's a surprise
snoring and you just like
did something about it
or
do you mean like
he was sound asleep so i took off his
sleep apnea machine or i put on a sleep
apnea machine yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah because it's yeah it made my
work day go amazingly well so is she
saying like
like tavis said are you the driver
yeah
that'd be funny it'd be funny if she saw
this while she was like in an uber or
something like that
um yeah
yeah oh this is a transfer station
waiting for the bus okay yeah yeah
or he was snoring
and then she like nudged him to wake up
because that's how
she wakes people up you're saying
and that made her day like just to
nudge somebody
um
but if she woke him up so
and told him to pay his fare like if the
misdirector she was driving the bus then
she woke
so maybe like waking him up
is kind of like the setup to the joke of
i woke him up because he was snoring but
it was really because he hadn't paid yet
or because it was his stop
or
you wanted what drugs he was on
or um
i don't know is
i think
there's a few okay i think we can
simplify the joke she's like i saw a guy
sitting in the transfer station waiting
for the next bus and he was sound asleep
snoring
i think it could just be
i saw a guy on the bus
and he was snoring
like simplifying the setup is gonna help
the punch hit harder as well
so
getting to that part quicker shortening
the setup way down will help
um
denise said she took his luggage
or his newspaper or his coffee
that works
um
i'm just trying to think like what
what's that where's the surprise
there's still not a what it is is that
there's not a stake
there's not an emotional stake
here
like
what's the word
um
but is it if it's i saw a guy like bobby
said i saw a guy snoring on the bus and
it made me laugh that's like the setup
essentially
so why did she laugh we're assuming she
laughed because he was snoring loudly
he was snoring in a funny way
she laughed because
um
he missed his stop
she laughed because he was in his
pajamas
she laughed because
maybe it's something with her like she
wasn't actually on the bus
she was at home
[Music]
um
you know i'm trying to think about if
the setup is i saw a guy snoring on the
bus and it made me laugh then like the
misdirect
needs to be around
yeah she laughed because she was able to
rob him
um
i don't know but i feel like if this was
a super chat we could have done a better
job it's a really you know what that's a
really good point that's a really good
point yoshi and i think
for hannah not even being on the live
stream anymore i think she got all the
feedback she can handle there
but thank you for posting genuinely yeah
for sure
uh zeb valentine my guy
yeah exhibited zebza
kid
my brother said he likes his women like
he likes his coffee
he doesn't like coffee tags he doesn't
like the way they taste but loves the
way they smell
that's some joe biden brew
i thought this i thought the joke was
that his brother was gay
yeah i thought that's where the
misdirect was going
yes
but i think the tags confused it yeah
the joe biden brew doesn't yeah
yeah the joe biden brew i get because i
think he's been accused of like smelling
people's hair oh okay well you've yeah
that you got to make a big leap to make
that connection
um my brother said he likes his women
like he likes his coffee he doesn't like
coffee
that's funny i think just that by itself
is just
enough
yeah
so in the tag could literally be so he's
so i have a gay brother
like
and that could just be the tag if you
have i mean if your brother's gay though
like
you don't want to make that joke for the
sake of oh it's a misdirect that he like
you know you want to be true and
authentic
um
yeah
i don't know why but like he doesn't
like coffee he just likes cream i don't
know why that's just funny to me
it makes me feel sexual
oh i wasn't even trying to make it feel
sexual but it does
i think i was just trying to like do a
coffee reference of something different
than just coffee yeah
yeah and denise brings up a good point
why doesn't he like coffee too strong
is it too bitter
yeah stains his teeth
yes
or like
um beans
makes you poop
caffeine decaf
i also think i mean if it's too
expensive
okay
that's not bad denise
that they're too the coffee's too
expensive
overpriced
maybe something like that and then it's
a joke about him liking prostitutes or
something
yeah
i don't know
but what this this
if it's true but this almost feels like
he just kind of made it up for the sake
of a joke
for sure yeah or like
like coffee he prefers tea
and then what kind of tea is it
yeah
yeah well we hope that helps their zeb i
don't even know if zeb is still watching
um
but yeah that was good feedback
oh and i was laughing earlier because
steve
said
that um he's pretty sure my hair can pop
on and off like a lego guy
it does look like the lego boots
you think so
it does because i do have legos in the
house and it looks like i could just do
like this
you wish you could
you're just jealous i have hair i think
that's what it is
so funny my hair has gotten roasted a
lot
tonight that's fine isn't the first time
either but i guess it's a good problem
to have
you know
uh
let's see what's next yeah uh this is
tavis
i got one from tavis here
it's on you
you say it's on mute
it's on you it's on me
yeah oh okay uh tavis
did you know
if you leave a can of coke open the
liquid kind of solidifies
my sister drinks that
yeah she drinks it whenever she asks me
for a coke
i just don't
i just i like tavis because i remember
when i had kovad and we did this he
brought me to life i was literally about
to fall asleep on the live stream from
covid and then his joke brought me back
to life but this one makes me wish i had
coveted again um
would you rather
have would you rather read this joke or
have coveted i it's that's quite a
conundrum
a savagery
um
but uh oh john i want to say that john
had a savage tag on the last joke the ol
uh
for i like my woman like i like my
coffee ground up and in the freezer
that is so dark
but
it works better it works
[Laughter]
big facts
yeah john is is reading my mind i don't
think i get it
but this is how we write jokes everyone
this is the process we throw out ideas
and see what sticks you know you write
20 jokes and keep one so that's why we
do this so we're not trying to make
anyone feel bad it's all out of love
um
but yeah i think it's just did you know
if you leave a can of coke open the
liquid solidifies
my sister drinks that
yeah she drinks it whenever she asks me
for a coke i guess he's saying
that
he he's giving his sister
the coke
that's open
i guess
because at first i thought it was a coke
and cocaine reference yeah
but i don't see it unless like
it was a mist type or something it kind
of solidifies there could be a joke
about chewing the coke
um whatever she asked me for coke
that's what i thought it would be tavis
has written enough jokes that i think
you can tell that it's like the joke
structure it's kind of like where's
maybe and maybe you were thinking the
misdirect is that
oh
i she drinks the coke like i'm giving
her the cocoa maybe that's the misdirect
but it's just not reading
like that um and part of it i think is
something we talk about in here before
is like setting up a joke with a
question
um
you really want to speak in statements
as opposed to questions you know um
i learned that from rodney perry
when the first interview i did with him
he was come out working with
he used to open up for george lopez a
lot
and he he used to set up all his jokes
with a question rodney did and he said
after one of the shows
uh george was like if you set up one
more joke with a question he's like
we're done working together
so it's um
asking a ques you really want to tell
the audience more than just ask them
because if you ask a question then that
leads
opportunity for them to yell out or now
they're thinking instead of listening to
you
so
it could be i learned
that leaving a can of coke open
makes it solidify
and then there could be a misdirect
around like because your sister gave it
to you or
you drank a coke that you found on the
street or something um
yeah there's just no like set up punch
here really which tavis says is super
fair so yeah
yeah i mean that's feedback you know we
don't have to solve every single joke
for sure like
there's feedback and just saying there's
no structure we don't have to solve
everything for these people you know
what i mean
yeah
no that's a it's a it's a good point
because we've been through it we've been
you know we've given each other feedback
and we've been like where's the joke
and that could be the feedback that's
like oh right there is no yeah
yeah and that's why
when you first when you first wrote it
you're like oh this is going to kill him
exactly
oh yeah carol said what is the reason
the sister drinks the old coke he
doesn't like his sister
gives her leftovers she prefers solid
coke yeah so
um
yeah so yeah a little more
yeah a little misdirect there buddy but
tavis is here like every week and we
appreciate you
so thanks for being a good sport there
um
yeah he really is
i'll never forget having covert in that
hotel room about to pass out and i heard
his joke
and i laughed came back to life i was
like all right let's end it on that
bring me back to life
uh
oh snap super chat from thomas
oh my yo let's go
let's go
yo thomas valentine thanks hot breath
for the comedy writer's material
yo
let's
go
thomas thanks buddy
give him that super chat horn there
nice
um
thank you so much thomas
oh i love being i had
i had someone that just found the show
like two days ago he's a comic named
crux who was just searching comic advice
on youtube and found the channel and was
reached out about how helpful it was i
just love hearing that stuff
um
is j-like next oh wait bobby wrote
something i saw my name in it
um
[Music]
i'm writing a sketch for joel and myself
as old ladies gossiping in church saying
stuff like
you know jolene i'd rather skin my own
teeth than gossip in church but have you
heard about bessie jessup apparently her
dentures ain't the only thing popping in
and out of her mouth
and joel replies oh my heavenly day
oh and i'm dressed up as an old lady i
guess
is that is that pc is that old face is
that a thing now
dressing up an old face you know like
it's black face but it's old face
i think so
that would be fun though
i mean like the skit i'm totally down to
do the sketch
that is funny
be like mama's family wasn't she was was
that a dude dressed like a female
no
oh she's the female with like a wig on
like i have a wig on i guess yeah all
right no that was like a real hair
that was a real hair
oh i didn't realize that
yo thomas i'm just seeing that super
chat it makes my hard heart smile
yeah vicky lawrence
all right that's great yeah bobby i'm
totally down
um
to shoot some sketches though i do say
oh my heavenly day i picked it up for my
mother-in-law she says oh my heavenly
day and all my heavens and hither and
yawn she says hither and yawn as well
which is really funny
that's so funny i say all of them
hey hither and yawn
john stallings
okay all right
all right i i've condensed my dating
profile recently too i'm old have a good
job and better life insurance
i should be attracting way more milfs
than i have been
okay
um
i think maybe cougars would have been
better
uh
but also
i really don't know how you feel about
it
in terms of like are you excited about
the fact that you're
attracting more mils so like there's
just an emotional part here that's
missing for me
yeah and there's no misdirect right now
it's kind of like a statement it's like
set up
i've condensed my dating profile to i'm
old have a good job and better life
insurance
there's no
there's no misdirect it's kind of like i
should
have way more milks than i do you know
there's no
yeah and i think the emotional
connection for me was just like
yeah what is the surprise
at the end now
versus how you started
like
it's almost like i'm pissed off
at dating i recently changed my dating
profile to old good job and good life
insurance
i can't believe i don't have more
cougars than i have you mean like
or maybe the joke is all you're
attracting are cougars
yeah maybe it's like
dating is frustrating
um
and then it's like my profile says i'm
old have a good job and better life
insurance but my replies say i'm a
grandpa or something so
that's also a way of saying i'm only
attracting
old people
without saying i'm only attracting old
people you know it's like
but my replies say i'm a grandpa or
something
yeah yeah yeah i think even like
uh
i'm getting requests
for birthday money and cards like the
grandpa part of it what does grandpa do
you mean
like you're requested to
like
do grandpa like stuff
and again that's one also one of those
things that like if you make fun of
yourself here it'll work better for the
joke
yeah yeah
kind of punching down and being like i
should be attracting more cougars or
more yeah it's more of like it's a
reflection of something wrong with you
not the people you're attracting
yeah
oh and he said i was going more for who
wants to take care of me until i die
then get paid
well then yeah say that
like
if you're if you're setting up a profile
to be a sugar daddy then like say that
in the setup
yeah it's almost like i'm attracting
uh
i'm attracting cougars
and not
anna nicole smith's oh did somebody just
say uh carol said that yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
but i like i like grannies
instead of because then it's like you're
attracting something boring instead of
something like a cougar sounds exciting
and nicole smith sounds exciting so i
think
you attracting like boring grannies will
be a funny misdirect instead of like
yeah
yeah no that's funny nice
there you go john
thanks for posting there
um
where are dude there are so many
comments
comically funny had one
comically funny you say
oh my heavens oh my heavenly day it was
she posted two there we go okay john
okay i see
i see jayla has one
is it my turn at yours
it's yours we're fading we're fading
this is our longest one yet we're like
we're like treading water over here
we're like what
um
we're in it baby uh when i first heard
of gilbert's death on the news i didn't
believe it but reality struck when 15
000 tiny hotel shampoos suddenly
appeared on craigslist
i guess does he say something about tiny
hotel shampoos or
did he just did he collect them or
i think i guess you have to know
of this premise which i don't i just
think it's a funny thing that tiny
hotel's shampoo suddenly appeared on
christ yeah i do too i took it that he
was a road comic so collected a lot of
them i like made that connection but um
okay but it's still funny yeah i think
yeah
i like it
nice
that is hilarious
um
that
nice
all right
all right here we go nice j leg thanks
buddy
um
next
no
joke
joe
i'm trying to find i want to make sure
i'm not missing it but
comically funny
or is that a different one
where is where's theirs
says i find it difficult writing jokes
um
i'm not seeing it where
if he's
writing jokes while suffering
it's the second one
ah okay
here we go
yeah all right joke i find it difficult
writing jokes while whilst having social
anxiety here's my latest knock knock
i can never force myself to find out
who's there
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i like that
i like that too
yeah it's silly and very fun social
anxiety i can never force myself to find
out who's there
i like it
[Music]
i'm with it that's
i'm with that too that's solid solid
solid profile picture there too that's
cool beans
cool
beans oh nice thanks for sharing
um
let me see
i think michael
michael the chairman
um growing up my dad would send me a
birthday card every year
and he's
wait
sorry growing up my dad would send me a
birthday card every year and he would
always sign it the same way may god be
with you
love daddy xoxo
i love
where the setup is there's just there's
no misdirect here you know
and what's so funny about doing this
every week is that
we
like each week there's almost like
common themes
and like it seems like this week the
theme is like
where's like the misdirect you know what
i mean and like joke structure ask
yourself
what is the setup and then what is the
punch line oh and he said there's a
second part
oh there is a second part
the second part is
and i would turn to my mom and say can
you believe it
he wants god to be with me but he isn't
okay there we go
so i think we can literally yeah yeah
that's good
[Laughter]
i think
literally
it could just be summed up of like he
would always sign it the same way may
god be with you because i won't be
or because i'm not
love daddy xoxo
so now it's condensed it's edited it it
says the same thing but much quicker
that's very very
that's a funny joke i like it though
yeah yeah that's what that's great
michael i like that man
yeah nice i'm glad we got that second
part because i was just like please
that's not
[Laughter]
but sometimes they like review they like
hold for some reason youtube held that
comment for review the second part
i guess yeah absentee ads triggered the
algorithm
yeah love daddy xoxo obviously it
triggers something
let's see this may be the last one here
um
this may be the last one from
all andrew rhinos have some of the
thickest skin in the animal kingdom
they believe it develops in childhood
due to being fat and ugly with the horn
growing out of their face
is there a second part
to this
savage
yes you're coming in with it
oh snap or is this like a double
enchanter like rhinos being is that what
you call republicans
is that i know i think
they have thick skins so they can you
know
take
take their roasts and stuff
being fat and ugly and having i think
yeah i'm guessing the misdirect is
because oh andrew posted i don't know
either
uh
that's he he just did this emoji this
emoji right here he's like i don't know
i just want to hear my name on the the
thing i don't know i just read this on
reddit and then pasted it here
um
rhinos is a term
for
republicans in name only
oh i didn't know that
so is this about the actual
rhino the animal
i think so yeah
thickest skin animal
i think i don't know andrew andrew
doesn't know andrew just did this so i
don't know
but i think felix yeah i agree with
felix saying
he means their develop thick skin from
being bullied for being fat and ugly
oh okay
andrew said i'm baffled at how often
we don't get the joke
and here's the thing we're pretty smart
it's not us
trust me andrew we are just as baffled
as you are
at some of the things people post on
here
and it's like yes we can get this
conceptually okay he's saying that the
rhino
it's thick skin because it's fat and
ugly because it was bullied we get the
idea
but we don't get the joke they're the
structurally
andrew
walkenstein or stein
we get what people are trying to say but
we're also trying to get people to write
jokes
and yes
but the audience isn't gonna be like oh
well we get the premise so we'll just
meet you halfway and laugh you're like
no where's the set up punch misdirect
here
yes
i'm baffled
that you haven't posted a joke andrew
walkenstein
how about that
[Laughter]
you sound exactly like the white dudes i
make fun of on stage
[Laughter]
hilarious
that's great john said he's saying it's
logical but not comical that's hilarious
yeah
that's so funny
but yeah
koga
comically funny so we could do a show
just roasting bad jokes
here's the thing we don't wanna be bad
no no we're rooting for y'all we're
if andrew
bartlett we're talking i'm talking to
you andrew wolkenstein
but if andrew posts a joke and then post
this emoji after it
this is what he posted this is what he
posted
after the joke andrew doesn't even know
so i'm baffled that andrew posted a joke
that he doesn't know
he's just like i don't know guys
i just i just want to participate for
the algorithm and we appreciate it
andrew bartlett
but andrew walkenstein
you're on thin ice buddy
yeah
uh so andrew bartlett the joke itself i
think there is a i like the premise of
having thick skin
is strange
it's um
i think you can do a comparison to
almost being like childhood right like
how having that thickest skin
um
and having something grow
out of your face
relates back to you that's the other
thing about this joke this feels like
just like something that's getting read
off versus how does it relate back to
you so i think you have like making it
personal would help the joke like almost
like rhinos have some of the thickest
skin in the animal kingdom they develop
it from being fat and ugly with a horn
growing out of their face
i had a pimple
when i was younger so i get it
it's almost like now that's the punch
line or like i had something grown out
of my face as a kid
and now i have the thickest skin kind of
thing so so but just some level of
personalization would help the joke
rather than it's sounding like
something right off of a tootsie roll
in fact you mean like it feels like a
bubble gum wrap you're like facts rhinos
have thick skin because they develop
as a childhood with
you know a horn on their face kind of
thing so there's something there
nice
all right
so maybe the last one here
is thomas valentine i come from a broken
family we're all in therapy
that's not the last one
oh yes it is
is it not
oh sam has one
i gotta go to a show
i gotta go develop my own comedy here
people
where are you going today
i'm going to limerick i'm doing one of
the like the
they do the show and then the lightning
round so i'm on the actual show but i
want to go to cats beforehand
um
yeah
there's no misdirect
really yeah i come from a broken family
we're all in therapy so it's basically
the mystery needs to be around like
broken
how we're assuming it's a broken family
so like maybe your parents are divorced
maybe people don't get along
but maybe it's like you're physically
broken
to where like we all have a we're the
same cast
or
yeah we're all in therapy
uh
but we just all broke our foots or we
all
just got ran over by
um
yeah i think there's a broken we were in
a we were in a family we're in a car
crash or something
yeah we were in a car crash
yeah yeah that'd be funny
yeah nice
i don't like that feeling said the
thinnest skin award goes to will smith
felix
that's very sad
all right
let's do sam's last and michael said he
put another one but we we only read one
just for the the sake of time
um
but let's do sam's and then let's land
the plane
all right
every time
myself in the mirror i'm disappointed
i always wish i had a few more inches i
get it ladies i'm just not tall enough
all right
i see the misdirect kind of yeah
in referencing to
your genitalia versus your height
but i think it needs to be clear
that you're
uh
making that reference so
my thought is every time i look in the
mirror and i look down i'm disappointed
i always wish i had a few more inches i
get it ladies i'm just not tall enough
so just saying looking down looking down
yeah that's great
yeah just shifts it to where
now it's directionally somewhere
different and now you've
taken it in a totally different place
because you're looking down you're
probably just looking down because
you're short
and it built yeah i like it it builds up
the misdirect more
yeah so it helps them
to actually see it yeah i like that
that's a great edit there nice
looking down sounds better yeah sam
likes that's a great edit there yoshi
ooh
you should do this you should do this
for a living you should
you know i i know people like andrew
wolkenstein are like i can't believe you
don't get these jokes that aren't really
jokes but
i feel good about that
savage
talk about savage we just did two hours
bruh
yeah yeah
man all right
oh
maybe we do like a timer maybe
maybe for everything we do there's like
a timer you know
yeah yeah we could do like a countdown
clock like they do on pti
do you know pti i do know pti it's
almost like
look so we could have like a timer
somewhere
so like for each thing we talk about
it's like maybe we talk about each topic
for five minutes and then joke feedback
is like two minutes per joke or
something
sure because we can just go you know
absolutely so
it'd be great to
[Music]
i don't mind
doing this but
it's um
it's evolving but i do like this could
just be like pti for comedy really
nice
pizza comedy i don't hate that hot
breath set list that was good too that's
i like that here's our set list yeah
nice
i like that i have to watch some pti
or ptp pardon the punch lines why aren't
the punchlines
do the comedy version of um
pti i like that
huh
well all right kids
we did it
we did it you're welcome
i mean thank you that's what i meant to
say thank you everyone
[Laughter]
uh i gotta write what's what's the other
word i need to write humble
[Laughter]
but thank you everyone for hanging out
and spending your valuable time with us
i mean this was our longest one but i
think we had like the most people
watching as well so
thank you guys all for hanging out
through all this
do subscribe to the youtube channel if
you haven't we're doing all sorts of
live streams on here i'll be back at 10
a.m tomorrow doing the right 10 club and
then tomorrow a live q a
so
there's a lot going on here at the
hopper at the verse so
subscribe and share this with your
fellow comedian let them know what's
goody out here in the hoodie
hmm
and until
then i think we're done
here we go y'all
we're dabbing
bye y'all
[Music]